Buenos días Santiago pues bastante
ambiente sobre todo en las partes
centrales de doja hemos cruzado varios
grupos de hinchas de Croacia están en
número con las banderas las banderas
pintadas sobre las mejillas pero también
los marroquíes que son digamos los más
bulliciosos estaban allí cantando en el
mercado central de esta ciudad Así que
todavía hay bien este gran ambiente que
ellos siempre traen a cada uno de los
partidos efectivamente usted bien lo
decía Esta es la disputa por el tercer
lugar es un partido importante para
Croacia que ya logró quedar ese segundo
en 1998 Hace 4 años Fue segundo y esta
vez pues más allá de querer salvar el
honor es de poder dar un buen final a
este mundial que estuvo muy disputado
por parte de los croatas que sufrieron
mucho esos dos partidos tanto de octavos
como de cuartos que finalmente se fueron
a la larga así que los croatas habían
llegado muy cansados al partido ante
Argentina ahora pues también es la
oportunidad para que Luca modric que va
está disputando ya su último partido de
un mundial pues pueda irse con una
medalla y de hecho cramarich decía que
esta es la oportunidad también para
regresar a casa un poco como una especie
de héroe inmortal si se tiene una
medalla y por el parte de los marroquíes
Bueno un poquito menos de hecho el
entrenador hablaba de que era un poco
como el puesto de los bobos un poco ir
por ese tercer puesto pero sea como sea
el caso es que el tercer puesto va a
llevarse además de la medalla un premio
de unos 27 millones de dólares y quien
quede cuarto 25 millones